it feels extraordinary yeah yeah I'm I'm  incredibly excited to be here this is a  big event I've never been at an event  like this so it's wonderful to be to be  in the company of these extraordinary  actors really is is that if the chief  pleasure of it you know all these  amazing actors all the people that they  announced today was really really  extraordinary he is a member of the the  intelligence world so that's really all  I can say someone I work together we did  a play on Broadway a few years ago so  I'm really thrilled to be working with  him again yeah and he said absolutely  he's a total genius with actors and he  surrounded himself with the best doctors  in the world I thank you for some of  them and so yeah  you